je vous ai expliqué en quoi consiste le
télé-acha d'aujourd'hui nous avons
décidé de descendre dans la rue pour
promotionner les porte-bonheur mais les
vrais vous en avez
tant de bonheur non je suis pas très
superstitieux vous connaissez la
superstition donc des bossubs avec
toucher la boss d'un bossus à porte de
la chance est-ce que vous saviez ça
j'aime pas tellement genre de choses
parce que c'est basé sur la railleries
alors je vous présente donc le télé
achat d'aujourd'hui je venais avec moi
et donc pour différents vous avez le
droit de toucher cette bosse qui vous
apporte vous nous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure là la chance fermez les yeux
parce que sinon ferme les yeux
le service après-vente fonctionne 24
heures sur 24 donc sur minitel vous
tapez 36 15 la bosse